[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
weaponization of law enforcement against
their political opponent is something
straight out of the stalinist Russia
Horror Show
[Music]
under Joe Biden American Patriots are
being arrested and held in captivity
like animals these are people that
shouldn't have been there
[Music]
let there be no doubt the injustices
being done not only to me but to dozens
across our country will not stand and
we're not going to stand for it when
this election is over I will be the
president of the United States
you will be Vindicated and proud and the
Thugs and criminals who are corrupting
our justice system will be defeated
discredited and totally disgraced that's
what's happening
[Music]
does get arrested I'm still backing him
I'd have to see more evidence and not
all the evidence is out there and lots
of times the evidence that the far left
has is not true evidence
you can do whatever you feel